la mobilisation ne faiblit pas plusieurs
dizaines de milliers de personnes pour
soutenir le mouvement des chômeurs un
peu partout en france
un rapport confidentiel critiqué la
prise en charge de la délinquance des
mineurs un constat d'échec du système
tout entier
à washington la consultation de bill
clinton et paula jones sur une affaire
d'harcèlement c'est la première fois
qu'un président est amené à s'exprimer
deux mois après le carnage à louxor les
touristes continuent de déserter
l'egypte reportage dans la vallée des
rois faute sécurité et puis en marge des
défilés de haute couture découverte
d'une première d'atelier qui dirige
après 50 ans d'expérience les ateliers
de christian lacroix
madame monsieur bonsoir ouvrons ce
journal par les larmes de bonheur d'une
jeune française originaire de mulhouse
qui a donné la france son premier titre
mondial en natation victoire historique
aujourd'hui à perth en australie
roxana maracineanu a remporté la finale
du 200 m dos dames au cours des
championnats du monde florent gautreau
et patrick montel le chrono a tranché
mais les yeux hésitent encore faut-il
pleurer de rage ou de joie
roxana maracineanu a du mal à le croire
et pourtant c'est bien elle qui vient de
remporter le 200 m dos
c'est le premier titre mondial de la
natation française marachi nanou ici au
premier plan a construit sa victoire en
deux temps
150 m en embuscade et une remontée
fulgurante dans la dernière longueur
au bout de l'effort la française va la
favorite l'allemande dagmara the et
s'offre un nouveau record de france
roxana elle-même n'osait espérer un tel
dénouement
tellement comment comment sortir avec
l'aide américaine quelques avait l'air
plus forte avec nous à connaître tout
petit pas mais lui aussi est finalement
je me suis dit bon on peut faire comme
une quantité mais je pensais pas être
une marseillaise historique pour une
française atypique
roxana maracineanu est né en roumanie
elle vit aujourd'hui en france à
mulhouse
elles s'en prennent souvent en allemagne
la française a bénéficié il est vrai du
recul des chinoises ébranlée par les
affaires de dopage
elle a aussi confirmé le renouveau
tricolore les français au creux de la
vague depuis les jeux d'atlanta nage
désormais dans le grand bain mondial
la qualité de ce samedi marque
incontestablement par les manifestations
de soutien aux chômeurs cinq semaines
après le début du mouvement la
mobilisation était au rendez vous pour
cette journée nationale point d'orgue à
paris avec sous un ciel clair plus de
dix mille personnes encadrées par des
associations est en tête du cortège un
slogan tous ensemble on continue olivier
galzi quand les caddies sont vides la
misère se met en colère
l'urgence c'est l'urgence de la
situation qu'elles sont venues crier
aujourd'hui sur le pavé parisien comme
étant des gens qui m'avaient 2300 francs
par mois
la couture jambes
vers 1500 francs de plus par mois c'est
ce que réclame entre autres mesures
d'urgence les sommaires mais avec eux
cet après midi des étudiants des
salariés et même des retraités ont
manifesté leur solidarité
voilà ça touche aussi les étudiants
d'aller toujours en raison du recours
tous pourtant ne comprennent pas aussi
bien vers 17 heures ils étaient entre
10000 et 20000 à se disperser place de
la nation dans le calme
en revanche que d'ulm de l'autre côté de
la seine des échauffourées ont eu lieu
quelques cocktails molotov lancés sur
les forces de l'ordre pas une poignée de
mécontents rapidement dispersés voici
qui nous amène à toulouse où l'ampleur
de la manifestation fait l'une des
villes les plus mobilisés contre le
chômage et pour ruer pour réclamer une
réduction du temps de travail
de nombreux salariés se sont joints au
cortège du côté de nantes
là aussi l'appel des associations a été
entendu enfin l'exemple de marseille là
d'où est parti le mouvement tour de
france avec damien thévenot
c'est à toulouse que la manifestation
était la plus importante près de 6000
personnes ont défilé cet après midi dans
une ambiance musicale et sous un beau
soleil dans les cortèges chômeurs
salariés et retraités ont réclamé que la
réduction du temps de travail
il va falloir
que les salariés actuels comprennent
qu'il va falloir une baisse de salaire à
mon avis il faudra y passer parce que 32
heures avec le salaire actuel sans
baisse de salaire ce sera pas possible
même revendication même mobilisation à
nantes les 3000 manifestants ont réclamé
le rmi pour les moins de 25 ans et une
revalorisation de tous les minima
sociaux
après toulouse nantes et grenoble les
manifestations ont été de moyenne
ampleur à lille montpellier et bordeaux
entre 1000 et 2000 participants
mobilisation plus faible en revanche
dans l'est de la france entre 300 et 700
personnes à nancy metz et strasbourg
en tout plus d'une vingtaine de villes
en france se sont mobilisés aujourd'hui
enfin la participation à marseille était
attendu plus que c'est dans la cité
phocéenne qu'a débuté le mouvement des
chômeurs il ya quelques semaines
aujourd'hui les bouches du rhône ont
rassemblé quatre mille cinq cents
manifestants 2000 de moins que mardi
dernier
l'engagement du préfet de débloquer de
1000 francs d'aidé d'urgence aux plus
démunis a peut-être apaisé la colère de
certains chômeurs en tout cas ceux qui
ont participé aux manifestations
aujourd'hui sont bien décidés à se
battre jusqu'au bout
six mois après avoir pris la présidence
du rpr philippe sega lors du conseil
national du mouvement qui s'est tenue
cet après midi à paris philippe seguin
rassemble autour de lui les différents
courants de l'opposition à l'ordre du
jour les élections régionales la refonte
des statuts bref la rénovation du parti
à la tribune philippe séguin en a
profité pour dénoncer avec vigueur le
monde virtuel de lionel jospin reportage
carole comeau et vincent bouffartigue
philippe séguin et de bonne humeur
après six mois de doutes et
d'introspection le mouvement gaulliste
peaufine aujourd'hui sa rénovation
les militants ont été consultés et les
vieilles querelles sont maintenant
officiellement oublié après la remise à
l'ordre
il y aura maintenant je pense
aujourd'hui un accord à la fois sur les
objectifs le projet les moyens
tout va bien on est rassembler
réconcilier
je n'étais pas tout est fini qu'il n'y a
pas encore beaucoup de travail à faire
enfin l'année 98 comment ce lieu rouler
avec le rpr semble d'ailleurs retrouver
les faveurs du calendrier le mouvement
des chômeurs le dérapage du premier
ministre le moment est propice pour
s'attaquer au gouvernement jospin en est
réduit à se bâtir un monde imaginaire un
monde virtuel dont il attend qu'ils
soient compatibles avec son dogmatisme
alors c'est vrai pour le passé il
réécrit en conséquence l'histoire à sa
façon c'est vrai aussi pour le présent
c'est vrai aussi pour le présent dont il
refuse d'admettre les données les plus
évidentes et qu'il reconstitue à sa
convenance
un nouveau projet politique de nouveaux
statuts sans doute un nouveau nom pour
la première fois c'est par un vrai débat
interne que le rpr a décidé aujourd'hui
de son avenir philippe séguin s'était
donné six mois pour mener à bien la
rénovation du mouvement gaulliste ce
sera chose faite à la fin du mois lors
des assises nationales qui verront la
naissance d'un nouveau rpn juste à temps
pour se lancer dans la bataille des
élections régionales de mars prochain
de son côté françois bayrou présidente
de force démocrate ironise sur les
divisions au sein de la majorité
plurielle ou proposer l'écouté la
majorité plurielle c'est assez simple
c'est les premiers qui organisent des
manifestations contre les second sous
les applaudissements des troisièmes
c'est comme ça qu'on ont construit la
majorité plurielle mais tout le monde
voit bien que de cette majorité qui est
en voie de de décomposition de dilution
et de dégradations il ne restera bientôt
plus qu une novation grammaticales nous
allons avoir la majorité plurielle la
plus singulière de tout et la majorité
la plus singulière parce qu'à force
d'être plurielle elle ne sera plus
majoritaire du tout jean michel
carpentier m'en sort apparemment
l'opposition profitent de la situation
délicate dans laquelle se trouve le
gouvernement
oui bien sûr l'opposition a beau jeu de
s'en prendre à lionel jospin car c'est
la fin de l'état de grâce pour le
premier ministre qui se trouve à un
tournant celui qu'ont d'ailleurs connu
avant lui souvenez-vous jacques chirac
en 86 avec les étudiants en religion
nos puis michel rocard avec les
infirmières edouard balladur avec le
sehy paix et à la jupe et en décembre 95
avec la grève des transports c'est à
dire que six à huit mois après leur
arrivée presque tous les premiers
ministres depuis 15 ans ont subi des
mouvements sociaux
alors aujourd'hui à deux mois des
élections régionales et bien lionel
jospin est confronté à trois défis
premièrement tenir sa majorité
deuxièmement contrer une droite qui de
l'elysée jusqu au rpr et l'udf relève la
tête et retrouve son inspiration dans
des idées néo libérales et troisième
défi le mouvement social des chômeurs
devenus un véritable acteur politique
est probablement celui qui recueille le
plus d'écho auprès des français ce que
lionel jospin avait peut-être un peu
trop sous-estimé aux critiques de
l'opposition l'énergie spa a subi de
l'autre côté la pression de sa majorité
oui depuis trois semaines les
communistes et les verts poussent à
gauche pour deux raisons d'abord éviter
de se faire déborder eux mêmes sur le
terrain par des acteurs sociaux de plus
en plus dures et ensuite pour préserver
leur identité dans la majorité alors
pour reprendre tout le monde en main
bien le miel de lionel jospin risque de
devoir mener une politique de plus en
plus à gauche notamment sur les 35
heures et les minima sociaux tout en
gardant en tête qu'il lui faut maîtriser
le budget pour réussir l'euro pas facile
merci à jean michel carpentier à lyon où
se tient jusqu'à dimanche la convention
des candidats du front national aux
élections régionales plusieurs milliers
de personnes ont manifesté contre le
parti de jean-marie le pen reportage
michaël darmon didier guyot être les
premiers à partir en campagne c'est un
principe au front national la convention
des candidats du fn pour les prochaines
cantonales et régionales se réunit sur
les terres du lyonnais bruno gollnisch
le retour de connu et pas seulement
autour de moi c'est au tour de la
présidente de notre délégué général de
l'ensemble du bureau politique et les
cadres du mouvement
deux jours d'ateliers de séance plénière
les troupes sont réunis pour recevoir
les instructions comme celle de bruno
mégret de plus en plus soucieux de
redorer le blason de son parti renault
garde de ne pas donner de nous une image
opg monique ou dogmatique sachot
expliqué mais voilà certains militants
s'obstine à expliquer leur vision très
lepéniste de la géographie et oui pas
facile de changer les mentalités en deux
jours deux conventions de l'autre côté
de la ville on manifeste contre la
présence du front national lyon
syndicats des associations antiracistes
redescendre dans la rue pour cette
campagne
toujours à la recherche de la stratégie
contre le fc la samba et coûté tant que
le front national on représentera ce
danger pour nous on ne se lassera pas
bien sûr qu'on préférerait routier mais
le front national est là on est là
outils réunion du front national
dispositif policier et manifestation
anti fn
lionla tranquille donne classiquement
les trois coups d'une nouvelle campagne
électorale un rapport confidentiel
concernant la délinquance des mineurs et
demandé notamment par le ministère de
l'intérieur et de la justice
et bien ce rapport dresse un constat
d'échec de la politique actuelle et
révèlent les carences et les
dysfonctionnements du système
reportage valérie ermite et alain look
at you plus jeunes en plus violent et
plus visible les derniers incidents de
strasbourg ont replacé le problème de la
délinquance des mineurs au coeur des
débats
le rapport qui vient d'être remis à
trois ministères différents le relance
le diagnostic qui y est très sévère
parlant l'inadaptation des réponses
institutionnelles aux formes aiguës de
la délinquance juvénile
les structures d'accueil et le personnel
sont montrés du doigt des structures
jugées mallarmé mal organisés pour
s'occuper des cas les plus compliqués un
vrai constat d'échec de l'an prise en
charge actuelle des délais
quand les plus difficiles un constat
bien trop dur pour les syndicats de la
pjj la protection judiciaire de la
jeunesse est très sévère et très injuste
à notre avis puisqu'il dit que les
services de la présidence ne prennent
pas en charge c'est jamais prises en
difficulté c'est totalement faux et le
dire comme ça c'est très des
mobilisateurs pour la profession qui est
consciente qu'elle doit diversifier les
modes de prise en charge à compter
nouvelle réponse ne s'est pas en
dévalorisant totalement notre travail
qu'on va réussir à relever c'est la
profession déficit des structures en
milieu ouvert mais aussi de la prison
qui dans sa forme actuelle est jugée
totalement inadapté pour les mineurs
enfin les auteurs du rapport s'intéresse
à la justice stigmatisant les délais de
jugement trop long et les décisions
prises par les juges prise mais non
appliquée faute de moyens mobilisés le
procure la république obligé le juge
pour aboutir sur une main d'exécution de
justice a du sens oui s'est
décrédibilisé le 6 il faut créer des
structures qui accueillent des jeunes
donc effectivement une fois la fois plus
de moyens mais organiser autrement
donc il faut repenser la profession
génisses à la jeunesse repenser les
missions de la pjj
c'est aussi ce que préconise le rapport
réfléchir aux structures et poursuivre
l'expérience des petites unités
d'encadrement le rapport lance des
pistes on est un vaste chantier
à charge pour le gouvernement d'apporter
des réponses le policier lyonnais
écroués après avoir tué en décembre
dernier à lyon un jeune homme de 24 ans
avec un fusil à pompe se pose ici a été
révoqué cet après midi c'est ce que
vient d'annoncer le ministère de
l'intérieur
les deux français retenus depuis plus de
deux ans en inde tous deux membres de
l'équipage du gala t sont arrivés ce
matin à paris libéré sous caution et
pour raisons humanitaires pour l'instant
la justice indienne ne les autorise à
rester en france que quatre mois mathieu
chez yann gicquel philippe et françois
était parti à la recherche d'une épave
coulé dans les eaux indiennes
impôts rêve de gosse laventure a mal
tourné accusée d'espionnage par les
autorités
ils reviennent après plus de deux ans de
détention perdre on peut dire qu'à mon
âge pour deux ans et beaucoup de profs
que l'on porte aux délicates heure par
heure
besoin d'un peu de temps pour se
retrouver retrouver ses proches après de
longs mois d'attentes bloqués dans ce
port indien à quelques pas de leur
bateau le galatée a résonné dès 1995
une accusation d'espionnage cinq mois de
prison puis une liberté surveillée
philippe et françois n'ont alors plus
qu'à attendre
clamant leur innocence
les autorités en cours par se rendre
compte de ce qu'était vraiment la faire
et c'est une voiture pour nous puisque
la caf on a priori
on est confiant confiant mais pas
complètement soulagé pour l'instant il
ne bénéficie que d'une libération
temporaire leur bateau est toujours
entre les mains de la justice indienne
et ils ne seront qu'à la fin du mois
s'ils bénéficient ou non d'un non lieu
la visite de jacques chirac en inde
prévue dans quelques jours pourrait
aider à clore définitivement le dossier
à manille aux philippines des milliers
d'enfants de différents pays d'asie
défilent pour protester contre le
travail des enfants dans le monde
cette marche unique en son genre et le
coup d'envoi d'une vaste campagne pour
dénoncer les quelques 250 millions de
mineurs forcé à travailler dans le monde
d'autres marches semblables auront lieu
au brésil en argentine et aux états unis
le mois prochain puis en europe
700 groupes dans 97 pays participant au
mouvement
ils marcheront pendant cinq à six mois
avec et la fin une conférence
exceptionnelle à genève aux états unis
l'événement très médiatique que
retransmis sur la plupart des chaînes de
télévision la confrontation près de la
maison blanche entre bill clinton et
paula jones qui le poursuit pour
harcèlement sexuel c'est la première
fois qu'un président des états unis
t'amener à témoigner comme accusés dans
le cadre d'une procédure judiciaire le
face à face entre paula jones et le
président devraient durer plusieurs
heures sur place
maryse bureau entouré d'une meute de
journalistes il y a visiblement
quelqu'un de très intéressant au milieu
de cette cohue le nombre de caméras est
à la hauteur de l'événement c'est donc
elle qu'ils attendent que nous attendons
pour la jones pour personne
la petite provinciale américaine sur
laquelle le tout washington n'aurait pas
parié un dollar il ya quatre ans et bien
la voilà
elle ne dit pas un mot à la presse les
elle sourit car celles qui accusent le
président américain de harcèlement
sexuel a déjà gagné une belle bataille
dans quelques secondes dans ce building
elle sera face à face avec bill clinton
pour la jones le cauchemar du président
américain il affiché un air détendu ce
matin en quittant la maison blanche
mais il a quand même opté pour une
entrée plus discrète dans
femme lieu de la confrontation alors que
vont-ils se dire derrière cette porte à
huit clos bill clinton at il oui ou non
baisser son pantalon en 91 devant paula
jones lui at il demandé une petite
faveur
les badauds ou des avis partagés je
pense que c'est terrible parce qu'elle a
obtenu ce qu'elle voulait de la
publicité être célèbre et elle a gagné
moi j'ai pas de punir vraiment c'est sa
parole contre celle du président les ca
des pins qui ont eu chaud contre la
confrontation devrait durer toute la
journée et pendant ce temps à
l'extérieur la porte parole de paula
jones fait patienter les journalistes
elle explique que la toute nouvelle
information donnée ce matin par le
washington post est en leur faveur
selon ce journal clinton pourrait
aujourd'hui reconnaître première fois
qu'un policier a bien amener paula jones
dans sa suite en 91
mais il n'ira lui avoir fait des avances
à deux pas de la maison blanche
le face à face entre bill clinton et
paula jones pourrait donc durer
plusieurs heures le temps pour les
avocats de paula jones de littéralement
cuisiner le président américain sur sa
vie sexuelle et sur sa réputation de
coureur de jupons
c'est décidément une très très pénibles
journées pour bill clinton
et puis toujours aux états unis
l'industrie du tabac va payer la somme
faramineuse de 15 milliards de dollars à
l'état du texas et ce pour compenser les
dépenses de santé publique liés au
tabagisme c'est la première fois qu'un
accord de ce genre et de cette envergure
est passé en égypte situation tendue
dans la région de louxor avec un
accrochage entre la police et les
villageois qui refusait d'être expulsé
le bilan fait état de quatre morts et
onze blessés
une expulsion qui rentre dans le cadre
du renforcement de la sécurité autour de
cette région hautement touristique
depuis le massacre du 17 novembre qui a
provoqué la mort de 58 personnes la
région et totalement déserté par les
étrangers comme l'ont constaté charles
enderlin et mohammed moursi
aujourd'hui le temple de la reine
hatchepsout où s'est déroulé le massacre
est bien gardé
à côté la hausse les services monétaires
alors ça ne donnait sans part ça pas de
problème ici
les vendeurs de souvenirs de louxor
voudrait que les touristes reviennent
vite les affaires ici vont très mal
depuis deux mois
notre chance est ce que vous avez peur -
quelques dizaines d'étrangers seulement
visite ce temple un des plus beaux de la
haute egypte avant l'attentât des
milliers de touristes passé ici chaque
jour et on vient d'étendre superbe la
queue dans les musées
pas du tout on a fait ça tranquillement
la région qui vit presque exclusivement
du tourisme est sinistrée sur le nil et
dizaine de bateaux de croisière
attendent des jours meilleurs et les
calèches de carnac n'ont pas eu un seul
client depuis plus d'un mois
il n'y a pas de travail
nous vendons nos biens et les bijoux de
nos épouses pour survivre le
gouvernement a promis de nous donner des
prêts mais on ne voit rien rien venir
la situation n'est guère meilleure pour
le palace où agatha christie venait
passer l'hiver
il est presque vide 25 de ses 400
chambres sont occupées
une aubaine pour les rares clients qui
bénéficient d'un calme inespéré de prix
incroyablement bas et peuvent admirer
dans la solitude des magnifiques temples
de louxor la nuit cette crise est la
plus grave que traverse l'egypte ces
dernières n
elle touche la principale activité
économique du pays
le tourisme rapporte en effet aux
égyptiens ni milliards de francs par an
alors le gouvernement égyptien va tenter
de trouver rapidement une solution au
chômage qui risque d'être catastrophique
ici il va à planter des industries qui
ne soit pas lié au tourisme
mais cela prendra du temps peut-être
trop de temps pour le 7e anniversaire du
déclenchement de la guerre du golfe
d'anciens combattants britanniques ont
manifesté devant le ministère de la
défense geste symbolique ils ont rendu
leur médaille pour protester contre
l'inaction du gouvernement à l'égard de
ce que l'on appelle le syndrome de la
guerre du golfe en effet plusieurs
milliers de vétérans anglais mais aussi
américains et canadiens se plaignent de
fatigue chronique et de dépression
depuis leur mission dans le golfe en
turquie au lendemain de la dissolution
du parti islamiste auquel appartenait
l'ex premier ministre erbakan
les réactions se multiplient mais pas
d'appel à la violence que redoutaient
les autorités en effet le parti
islamiste de la prospérité représente 6
millions d'électeurs dans un pays où la
montée de l'islam est de plus en plus
forte
reportage philippe rochot jean louis
normandin un calme étonnant devant le
siège du ray face à istanbul après la
dissolution du parti qui agite beaucoup
plus les esprits que la rue le parti
islamique est fermé mais le drapeau est
toujours accroché là dans ce quartier de
faty le plus intégristes d'istanbul les
gens nous disent que leur et faé peut
être intervenu mais qu'il existe
toujours dans leur coeur
6 millions d'électeurs avaient voté pour
lui aux dernières élections partir f à
cela veut dire que nous sommes bénis par
dieu est chargé d'humanité toutes les
bonnes choses de notre monde
c'est leur ai failli nous les faits à la
mosquée fatih la police est présente
mais pas de violences
necmettin erbakan le patron déchu du ray
face à plessis fidèle au calme et il est
écouté
mais à la prière de midi
il n'y a pas que des partisans même chez
ces femmes très religieuse cette
étudiante nous dit que de toute façon
cela ne changera rien car un autre parti
tout aussi radical va prendre sa place
son ami veut nous convaincre que ce
n'est pas parce qu'elles portent le
foulard qu'elle est partisane des
islamistes durs et femmes beaucoup de
turcs dénonce les dérives de ce parti et
de son chef
son financement son caractère sectaire
la turquie est un pays démocratique il
ya des lois et ceux qui n'obéissent pas
ses lois même si ce sont des partis
politiques doivent payer c'est normal
necmettin erbakan a appelé ses partisans
à ne pas répondre aux provocations et à
garder leur calme
mais c'est oublier que c'est le même
homme qui disait en son temps le rsa
vaincra avec lui sans effusion de sang
c'est aussi pour cette déclaration que
son parti a été dissous en argentine
après les déclarations de l'ex capitaine
alfredo astiz qui affirme avoir
participé à de nombreuses exécutions et
ne ressentir aucun regret le président
de la république carlos menem a demandé
la comparution en justice de l'ancien
officier à saint pierre et miquelon le
naufrage d'un cargo grec hier au large
de l'archipel français a provoqué la
mort de 21 des 25 membres d'équipage
quatre marins seulement ont été rescapés
l'épave du cargo de 180 mètres de long
qui avait quitté vers rotterdam a été
coupée en deux et des centaines de
tonnes de mazout s'échappe de ses flancs
les rescapés dans trois philippins ont
été transportés à l'hôpital victime
d'hypothermie tout autre sujet avec un
retour en france à blois visite guidée
d'un aquarium hors du commun puisqu'il
réunit quelques 1200 piranhas ce rouge
véritable machine à dévorer comme l'ont
constaté laurent le job et nathalie
gallet en assistant à leur repas
quotidiens
tous les jours à 16h on nourrit les
piranhas piranhas au portugais ça veut
dire sécateur c'est peut-être un détail
pour vous mais pour ce poulet ça veut
dire beaucoup
déchiqueté le poulet en quelques minutes
le piranha à une plus petite gueule mais
d'énormes capacités exactement inverse
de la plupart de nos congénères
j'ai entendu dire c'est ce qu'annonce et
des anecdotes on sait pas si c'est vrai
aussi c'est faux que par exemple l'armée
française en guyane dont à chaque fois
qu'il partait en qui sortaient ils ont
emporté avec eux souvent assez souvent
des cadavres de moutons pour jeter dans
les dents les marques qu'ils allaient
traverser ou les petites rivières pour
éviter de se faire de se faire trop
attaquer le piranha source de tant de
fantasmes dentition effrayante appétit
féroce le sujet idéal pour nourrir nos
cauchemars de chair humaine cauchemar de
série z la réalité quotidienne du
piranha est bien différente
on y mange pas c'est un animal qui a un
comportement en tout pratiquement
inintéressant puisqu'il se cache sous
une chaussée puis latran lille attend la
prochaine fois où il va m'en vais comme
tous les poissons le piranha et donc
calme tranquille et timide comme tous
les poissons il ne devient frénétique
qu'une fois par jour lorsqu'il s'agit de
manger de quoi démystifier un peu son
image de monstres sanguinaires cela dit
il y en a un à qui ça doit faire une
belle crise coup d'envoi aujourd'hui des
défilés de la haute couture aujourd'hui
thierry mugler je trouve des lignes
fuselées car secte moon des belles
mécaniques des lignes prête à basculer
au moindre souffle
le tout baigné d'un blanc éclatant sa
mode s'inspire d'une barbarella des
temps modernes légèrement agressive
mangeuse d'hommes latex velours pour
mieux
vinet la nuit c'est en marge des
collections je vous propose de passer
dans les coulisses des ateliers avec la
découverte de celles qu'on appelle avec
respect
la première d'atelier 50 ans
d'expérience pour cette femme madame
janine qui a commencé le métier à 13 ans
reportage ce film et elle et bernard
puceau la petite musique des ciseaux de
mère en fille c'est une passion qui le
retient tôt comme le dessus là faudra
voir avec monsieur lacroix parce que ils
voulaient une chose très précis il
voulait que les le sata elle le même
esprit c'est à dire le même mot le même
accrochage de lumière que sur les
tableaux de du coup on demande la
princesse discret et s'est développé à
l'eau le rôle de madame jeannine
comprendre les rêves que christian
lacroix exprimant quelques mots ou en un
croquis à peine ex qui s'est elle dite
ses troupes premières mains aux doigts
de fée des centaines d'heures de travail
pour chaque robe beaucoup de poésie et
un brin d'humour plus porté que c'est
comme quand on fait pour d'une pape oui
quand elles feront tard plus que trois
jours pour tout finir une soixantaine de
roms menées dans ses ateliers
alors forcément madame jeannine n'a pas
une minute à perdre
le signal vient d'être donné christian
lacroix l'attend un étage plus bas dans
les salons pour les essayages la
première d'atelier sur le pied de guerre
prêt à passer un examen au nom de son
équipe il faut qu'elle ait su traduire
l'aspiration du couturier
l'alluré générale de la robella habiter
pour la première fois par ses mannequins
qui prêtent leurs mesures parfaite à
l'élaboration de la collection madame
jeannine propose christian lacroix jauge
et tranche tout un cérémonial à
respecter dans les règles de l'art
madame jeannine était là pour
l'ouverture de la maison lacroix il y à
11 ans elle l'a vu grandir
nourri par le succès la reconnaissance
était là dès le premier jour il y avait
rien quand je suis arrivé que christian
lacroix m'a dit que c'était moi qui
prenais comme première je suis venu un
jour et puis on a commandé tout avec la
personne qui s'occupait de sa jusqu'à la
moindre est pâle parce qu'ils avaient
même pas une et paniers un bout de bol
du pierrier luc 55 ans qu'elle exerce
son métier dans l'ombre 55 ans et
toujours aucune intention de s'arrêter
un jour il faudra bien y songer dit elle
mais ça sera terrible déception
aujourd'hui pour surya bonaly ce sixième
seulement des championnats d'europe de
patinage artistique à milan une
satisfaction quand même pour le patinage
français avec la médaille de bronze du
couple anissina pèsera reportage vienne
la voix et andré germain
ce joli couple en progrès constants
depuis quatre ans a obtenu une logique
récompense à ses efforts
gwendal peizerat est un borromeo marina
anissina est une juliette forte et
courageuse ils peuvent avoir de
légitimes ambitions pour les jeux
olympiques
en revanche la déception est venue cet
après-midi de surya bonaly après un bon
début de programme
son patinage s'est ensuite désagréger
mal remise de sa blessure au talon qui
la fait encore souffrir et à court
d'entraînement
surya a échoué son courage n'a pas suffi
encore fragile
c'est dur quand le ministère n'a encore
possible mais quatre elle qui rêvait
d'un septième sacre européen a dû se
contenter d'une 6e place peu
encourageantes avant les jeux olympiques
de nagano
mais malgré sa déception elle aura
sûrement noté qu'elle reste l'une des
favorites du public
mais la nouvelle reine d'europe et
russes maria boutiche kaya a glissé tel
un signe sur la glace de ses rêves c'est
le premier titre européen pour cette
étudiante de 25 ans toujours bien placé
lors des différents championnats
internationaux mais jamais gagnante
aujourd'hui enfin elle aura eu sa part
de bonheur
en ski encore une belle performance
française jean luc crétier a pris la
deuxième place de la descente de wengen
en suisse
il termine à 57 5 centièmes du vainqueur
qui est l'autrichien andreas schifferer
ma victoire à new york c'est le départ
de la route de l'or trois monocoques
avec isabelle autissier par lee et
christophe aux gars pour une compétition
via le cap horn qui devrait durer plus
de deux mois christophe duchiron
frédérick basile pour être tout à fait
honnête
le départ de la route de l'or ce matin à
new york les américains s'en fiche et
autant que leurs vieilles paires de
baskets idéal à leurs petites habitudes
pour petites foulées les coureurs
courait sans s'arrêter à peine un coup
d'oeil en passant par san francisco sans
le moindre conclure américain il ya
forcément l'explication ils les
américains feront perdre non plus donc
un peu des deux niveau est élevé ils
sont pas informées nez et non pas la
culture
restons français soyons chauvins on
était chez nous ce matin new york public
sponsors médias trois skippers français
s'est logiquement la france qui devrait
gagner bon bateau et l'équipage dont une
belle sharks s'avancent j'espère que
tout ira bien jusqu'au bout quoi mais
c'est vrai que c'est très plaisant de
pouvoir partir dans des conditions
pareilles de se rendre à la fin tout est
réuni pour que ce soit bien quoi le
décor c'était bien les bateaux devant la
presqu'île de manhattan
la statue de la liberté qui attendait
pas il avait le tissier ça n'est qu'un
au revoir
bye bye new york et ses gratte ciel en
hiver 10h30
il parlait ses trois équipiers n'ont pas
une seconde à perdre il coupe la ligne
en premier comme des hommes pressés si
vous gagnez autissier la route de leur
est ouverte
les chercheurs de rompre il amène avant
d'arriver à san francisco il faudra
passer le cap horn 26 mille kilomètres
sur l'eau au moins deux mois de voyage
quatre à cinq à bord serrés comme des
sardines ou presque à l'intérieur du
bateau les bateaux sous le pont de
verrazano là où chaque année s'entassent
les milliers de coureurs du marathon de
new york à leur manière parliez
autissier augagneur mythifié sont des
marathoniens cette fois ils courent sur
la route de l'or de l'or à l'appel
l'appel du grand large
la belle hélène d'offenbach remise au
goût du jour l'opéra bouffe fait le tour
de france une trentaine de jeunes
comédiens chanteurs qui veulent à mu et
l'art lyrique vers un public rajeuni
pour sortir de la tradition les dieux de
l'olympe ont investi les marches de
l'assemblée nationale véronique
gallienne françoise maso je suis le fils
d'un gars maintenant je suis au reste
nous voudrions aures est devenu drag
queen cacace le prêtre danse la macarena
et la belle il n apparaît à la tête
d'une manie offenbach voulait une satire
l'opéra éclaté l'a actualisé
que ça se passe dans la grèce antique ça
n'a aucun sens de toute façon même
hélène il ya cinq siècles avant
jésus-christ c'était une femme une femme
de thé comme vous et moi et puis une
femme qui tombe amoureux c'est une femme
qui tombe amoureuse quel que soit le
siècle la reine s'ennuie dans son ménage
et rêvent d'autres horizons mais par
islam en est chassé par des rois énarque
d'aujourd'hui drapé dans la vésicule
dans l'esprit des fans ont fait un match
parfait dans les bacs ce qui reste dans
notre travail c'est l'essentiel c'est à
dire l'aspect parodique l'aspect
critique sur la société sur les gens sur
les êtres humains voilà et moi c'est ce
qui me plaît dans l'oeuf une batterie
comme molière c'est qu'on peut la propre
se l'approprier notre époque
un texte de 1864 pimentée de quelques
bons mots des costumes et des jeux de
scène décapant l'opéra éclaté veut
mettre l'art lyrique à la portée de tous
pour toutes époques pour tout public
comme chaque année en suisse festival de
montgolfières spectaculaire par leur
originalité
une centaine de ballons venus de toute
l'europe
oui
ainsi se termine cette édition je vous
en rappelle les principaux titres la
mobilisation ne faiblit pas plusieurs
dizaines de milliers de personnes pour
soutenir le mouvement des chômeurs un
peu partout en france
un rapport confidentiel critique la
prise en charge de la délinquance des
mineurs un constat d'échec que du
système tout entier
et puis natation victoire historique
aujourd'hui pour la france roxana
maracineanu a remporté la finale du 200
m dos dames aux championnats du monde de
strass tout de suite la météo présentée
par isabelle martinez 20h50 quand la
musique est bonne divertissement animé
par jean luc reichmann demain 7h dans
thé ou café catherine ceylac reçoit les
acteurs de la série entre père et mère à
milly demain dans polémique michèle
cotta reçoit bernard kouchner je vous
remercie de votre attention
excellente soirée à tout ça demain